yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master proof your legs from Norway this
is life oh god right yeah life oh God
let's go for the names Oh try to test
some lines from my book yeah we probably
will get the main line of the hook love
with bishop c3 andy sixx hmm yeah this
is a very rare move okay again
theoretically at least I capture twice
on d5 but is what bit of age 70 some
probably not the way to go also I can
take on c3 yeah let's let's play this
first it doesn't really matter much all
I played this and e5 next move I don't
think you can deviate from that probably
will castle our player bishop somewhere
it should be three or so or this one now
and then if I've the question is however
should I play five maybe I can stay
flexible and then wait for a moment
okay so it's not going for g4 or
anything like that I wonder yeah but
this is probably a bad idea something
like rupee eight I should probably
simply simply close the position just
posing to normal it who got set up I
probably should say hooked up I actually
know too how to pronounce that as a
German name okay so his idea is probably
to play G 4 I am I want to move the
night and play at five to get some
counter play and the question is to go
to e8 auto asian i used i used the h7
square now i want to anticipate g4 so
that on g4 i can use the weekend squares
on g5 and h4 okay yeah he's protecting
f5 covering at five so i need to learn i
need to prepared now interesting maybe
he wants to play a for evil but i can
always take and play a 550 go there for
and unless he's gotta be 50 or some
other spectacular move on it should be
it should be decent now for black maybe
Queen g2 but Angie 222 I can actually
take you for I don't even need to move
the light yeah then this is probably
even good for black I can just take a
play Bishop f5 now or step on some
better move I'm probably not this is
also simply a simply good he's got weak
palsy on on f4 and h3 yeah this looks
like a good move the night will be
excellent on a five I with the Queen
yeah I don't know i don't think you can
avoid the Queen trade no so we enter the
technical stage why this is basically
outplayed I just need to to pick up the
pieces now is full of fun porn
businesses they exchanged looks at the
end I should win the c-4 porn or
something on the queenside yeah it's a
bit of a model game for the for the hook
now this is what yo if you want in this
opening
neither fate is my next move probably
still yeah I want to go d 7 p-6 and he
needs to exchange this one work now yeah
now the c6 bonus is the problem c6 the
c4 c4 of course there is no way to
defend this this is the problem of this
Bishop is a very very bad piece on D to
it just done is limited by ahsan pawns
and it's very passive
yeah he's got no way to defend that he
can play Bishop see one night be 692 m
but there's 93 o is there something
better even hmm yeah it should be enough
the 75 hanging now the others d5 pawn
deserves somewhat isolated it cannot be
a beer protected by a pawn okay how to
do this now its motto are your kids I
can become maybe play Bishop a form
I know I need to write no no I know it
had I need to go here to have six this
is the right way to go Knight f6 and
just win the spawn I wasn't I didn't see
the maneuver at first this is just a
good here yeah probably anyway protected
Pest ponies son not bad so 95 95 if it
takes my actually winning yeah I morning
okay it's a bit stupid because it's got
three seconds but I wanted to make sure
that I really win yeah I guide i pick up
at five now if he goes kinking f6d six I
return and get the deep on so it's
waiting till you're running game ok yeah
this was a nice game well the weakness
of the sea for porn at the enter was the
decisive factor the problem really was
that will be played f4 here and the
problem was that here he doesn't have a
good way to prevent this these two poles
to be exchanged and then he's sitting on
all this week pawns he really needs to
make sure that he can play me five or so
in this position
and down this is really a really
problematic for white already he doesn't
have a good way to to make something
concrete happen this is a thought due to
this um not really working opposite a
five-foot sounds both good if I manage
to get rid of the bishop cm it's a it's
very very difficult for what let's see
one Bishop with such a stupid piece yeah
thanks for watching